it is 57 degrees in New York City in
January coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 46
[Music]
in the deep reaches of our universe and
starless spaces as here in New York City
time passes without impediment like a
ball rolling smoothly downhill forever
we are as humans drawn to extrapolate it
forward and backward to the coffee were
meant to get with a friend later this
afternoon to the siege of Constantinople
in 1204 to our illustrious future of
flying cars or to the time when you
tried to teach your sister to count when
she was three our meditations take us
far before and far beyond the present
moment so far we filled the gaps like
giant deep breaths in our heart but was
there a time when time wasn't what I
mean to say is did time ever begin let's
start with the Wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe or WMAP
a measuring device launched far into the
solar system in 2001 to take spherical
images of the universe at several
different frequencies with it we've
observed the first light emitted in our
universe some 380,000 years after the
Big Bang it's called the Cosmic
Microwave Background though we can't see
before that we can't extrapolate using
the speed of the expanding galaxies
backwards to determine that the Big Bang
happened around 13.7 billion years ago
we can't however get to the moment of
the Big Bang we can only probe with our
physics - right after - a second after -
a millisecond after - one unit of Planck
time roughly 10 to the negative 43
seconds after the Big Bang
many of our brightest believed at the
moment we can't see the moment of the
Big Bang is in fact a singularity and
infinitely hot an infinitely dense point
which when release created space and
time others disagree saying that our
universe is merely one in a series were
part of an infinite loop of expansion
and contraction but are we any closer to
conceiving of an answer to our question
as the OED defines it time is
in definite continued progress of events
in scientific terms it's the perpetual
transition from low entropy to high
entropy from a ordered state to a
confused one you can crack an egg but
you can't uncracked
remember the past but not the future the
truth is that the only reason we know
time is there is because we perceive it
we don't see it we see simply causes and
effects and conclude its presence as st.
Augustine said what then is time if no
one asks me I know what it is if I wish
to explain it to him who asks I do not
know so where are we just confuse
mouthpieces asking absurd questions like
when did time begin the question won't
even allow itself to be asked why why is
it unreachable well maybe there's an
answer in the beginning the Big Bang the
singularity is essentially a
discontinuity a break in our
understanding there wasn't and then
there was the concept of emergent
phenomena is extremely important it's
something that arises as the effect of
complex causes but is not analyzable
simply as the sum of their effect a
great example of emergent phenomena is
Darwinian evolution the formula that is
natural selection can't be arrived at
simply by studying the laws of physics
indeed before Darwin that's what every
biologist tried to do it was Darwin's
genius to see that the rule of evolution
emerged from the rule of physics which
is to say given the initial conditions
of the universe one could not predict
the emergence and rule of Darwinian
evolution on earth there is a
discontinuity between the two sets of
rules in the same way there's a
discontinuity between matter and life
from the particles of matter emerged the
organizing principle of life compatible
with matter but not analyzable as the
sum of its effects and here is where
time comes back into the picture matter
by its very definition is a function of
space it can move through time but taken
generally is not affected by with the
emergence of life space and time
converge life is the evolving complexity
of an organism and every stage of its
evolution corresponds with a moment in
time and vice-versa now there's one more
emergent phenomena in this sequence and
it's the most important to both us and
our discussion here the emergence of
the mind as life came from matter the
mind came from life from the increasing
complexity and growth of the brain
coupled with of all things the vocal
cords it was at the dawn of language
probably sometime in the last hundred
thousand years when the dual emergence
of symbols and the mind changed
everything again the use of language to
make symbols which are just names that
change in different contexts allowed for
the creation of a symbolic reality in
other words everything you see around
you the rule of symbolic reality is
again compatible with life but not
analyzable as the sum of its effects
it's something new our minds are
something new
whereas matter is a function of space
and life is a function of both space and
time our minds the human mind is purely
a function of time think about it what
is the one evident quality of thoughts
that they have to happen in sequence the
only way we can tell one idea from
another is by identifying the order in
which they occur this is why it's hard
actually impossible for us to fully wrap
our minds around time or to consider a
state in which it doesn't exist you
can't use a ruler to measure the absence
of space in a very real way what we
consider to be ourselves is composed of
time stuff and it is given to us of all
creatures to consider measure conserve
and extrapolate it as we wish we are
each of us time superheroes
[Music]
Wow